what we thought you could you could kind
of fill in as your hostess quizmaster
because we've got some questions lots of
questions this is a this is this is like
a friend's trivia oh oh she's gonna win
really I think you you there's some free
does some of you all know if they don't
know that I'm sure the audience will
know okay now to hear the questions okay
okay yes actually no cheating yeah
you're all complete yeah I know the
answer so I'd like you to put your hand
up if you know the answer yes question
what is Rachel wearing in her first ever
seen oh oh I can't answer that wedding
dress
no wedding dress is the correct answer
[Applause]
no question what is the next line after
this is about you being a brat wanting
what you can't have
Rhys can't have the only thing I can't
have is dairy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how did Rachel ruin the British trifle I
put beef in it beasts in and at the
bottom I layered beef into the trifle
you didn't you didn't you put shepherd's
pie right and Shepherd's pies not made
with beef it's made with lamb see
[Applause]
expect a landlord to know that yes yes
[Music]
what song does Rachel sing to get her
daughter to stop crying
baby got back is the correct is the
audience and for a bonus point Jennifer
would you like to sing the opening line
of the song I like big butts and I
cannot lie
[Music]
[Applause]
opening line of the theme song oh I
could have told you that you want to say
that so no one told you that it's gonna
be this way
[Music]
yes and this history for you to me oh
the questions when Ross dated Rachel why
did you feel it was fine to sleep with
other women and I know it it's because
he said we were on a break
[Applause]
[Music]